good afternoon everyone we're going to
get
started I want to welcome you to a
fireside chat with Vera Wells your first
question question should be where's the
fire it's a fire side chat without a
fireplace but uh in all other respects
we'll have that kind of informality and
uh and
friendliness uh today's event is part of
the
president's uh women of Yale lecture
series uh this was this is a series that
we uh launched uh last fall uh to
showcase the accomplishments of women
who graduated uh from the University
particularly uh women of color and uh
the idea is to Showcase people whose
leadership is emblematic of the success
of
co-education uh each of the speakers
that's been invited to participate in
this lecture series embodies in some way
uh the
Heritage uh of women at Yale over the
half century since women started to come
to Y college and the century and a half
since women started to come to other
parts of the
University this is a uh a kind of runup
to a celebration we will have in
2019 uh uh concer focused on 150 years
of women as students at Yale somewhere
and 50 years as students in Yale College
so
keep on the lookout for other
announcements of uh women of Yale
lectures there'll be at least one or two
a semester between now and 20 uh
19 I hope that some of you who are here
today were able to join us uh in the
fall I think it was October for our
inaugural uh uh women of Yale lecture
that was Maya Lynn and uh she gave us a
very wide ranging lecture that was quite
uh EX exciting I want to thank Marta
who's actually many of you know Marta
morett my wife uh
who Marta is a woman of yell in the
sense that she graduated from the public
health school in
1984 and uh with others who are here
tonight they generated the idea uh for a
president's lecture series featuring uh
women and she has been uh great uh
helping lead the group that's been
brainstorming who we should invite we
have some uh they're not confirmed yet
so I don't want to announce but if the
people who have been invited that I know
about confirm it's going to be pretty
exciting over the next couple of years
around here so tonight it's my pleasure
this afternoon it's my pleasure uh to
introduce to you our second speaker in
the series Vera Wells who's a member of
the class y college class of 1971 that
was the first year College graduating
class to include uh women after Yale
after Vera graduated from Yale she went
on to study organization and management
at Harvard's uh Kennedy School of
government she then consulted on
educational programs and did field
research in Africa in the
1970s uh working with uh various
International Development efforts and
then for 20 years she was an executive
at the nation National Broadcasting
Company
NBC uh she was in that capacity and
still is uh intensively involved in
supporting the Arts uh in New York City
we have uh seen uh Alvin Aly with Vera
we have seen Hamilton with Vera and it's
all very Vera Vera how many times have
you seen
Hamilton well over a dozen yeah
exactly exactly my point um when Vera
was an undergraduate at Yale she was
instrumental in the creation of a
residential College seminar uh for which
Sylvia Boon who was an eminent scholar
of African and women's art was first
recruited to teach at Yale Boon later
became the first black woman gr uh
granted tenure uh at Yale and many
people who don't know about sova's
career and her work know that fact uh
about her in Yale history uh Vera
collaborated with Professor Boon to
organize the chub conference on black
women which brought Maya Angelou
gwendelyn Brooks uh uh John herck Clark
uh Shirley Graham uh two boys to campus
all in December 19 uh 70 uh today syia
uh syia Vera uh directs uh the syvia
bone Memorial project and in that uh uh
uh capacity she oversees and provides
fun ing for a number of initiatives that
honor uh her this longtime fagy mentor
and close uh
friend we also all know Vera as an
active and dedicated alumni in 2007 Yale
celebrated her uh with a Yale medal H
that's the highest award that Yale gives
to um uh it's uh a longum night uh since
then she's served on the University
Council the yel development board uh and
the yel tomorrow campaign that was our
last fundraising campaign uh she is one
of the founders of Yale women which is
the Yale Women's alumni uh
organization uh she um is as I said the
founder of the Sylvia Boon project which
is based in Timothy Dwight college so
many of you affiliated with TD no Vera
uh from in that capacity she's been an
active fellow there and adviser for for
many many years with that I hope you
will join in welcoming to back to Yale
although she's here all the
time for this fireside chat Vera Wells
thank
you so uh the format we'll use as I said
as firesight chat I'll ask Vera a few
questions to get us started and then we
we're going to save lots of time for you
to chime in uh with your questions as
well so uh you can begin thinking about
what those might be uh now and then
we'll call on
you so very you were in the first
graduating class of women in in y
College how did you get here how did how
did you find yourself in that class well
it's interesting um and I guess I should
take a look around the audience but to
The Wider um world I'm not sure how many
people still realize that Yale was a
male school that it was one of the um
the Iva League schools that women did
not go to and I have to say that because
there are times when I still run into
people on campus including women who
seem to be shocked by that fact that
they don't realize that and it's part of
the thrust and why some of us are
particularly interested in having this
50th anniversary celebration so let me
just take you back to the
1960s um first of all I'm first
generation to go to college um neither
of my parents graduated from high school
and they had high aspirations for me and
I go off um to college having grown up
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania I had gone to
predominantly white schools most of my
time in Pittsburgh I was one of two
black people people in my graduating
class where I went to school at peab um
High School in Pittsburgh and so my
mother had been very interested in uh
having me go to a predominantly black
school I go off to Washington DC to
Howard University and before I finish I
get
married and I drop out of
school and uh I marry somebody who is
graduating from Howard's law school and
he
was um invited to be a reg Regal Heber
Smith
fellow um and he was then assigned to
come to New Haven to work with New Haven
legal assistants that's how I showed up
in New Haven in the late
1960s and so it was with him coming to
New Haven and um I start worked for
Community progress Incorporated and I
was just trying to be productive but I
didn't have my degree and when Yale
opened up for undergraduate women he
knew how angry my family was that I
didn't have my degree and he encouraged
me to apply and so I applied I was
interviewed by ELO wasman who is one of
the key people who was spearheading
co-education at Yale and who um
interviewed me as well as some others
and so that's how I got into the class
now Yale at that point in time was as
this all male School took in a thousand
leaders a year that's that was part of
the slogan know educating a thousand
Leaders The Assumption was always that
those leaders would be men and so when
they went coed it was a matter
of wanting to make sure that the women
who were coming in to the Freshman Class
transfers in the sophomore class and
transfers in the junior class would be
able to deal with whatever they found at
Yale and I say that in the point of view
that it was really the old
blue um Yale and although there were
people who were receptive to the idea of
women there were many who were not that
receptive to the idea of yaleo coet it's
you know right at the time when they
were considering being going coed at
Princeton or or Dartmouth and some came
behind us some were you know coming
along around the same time but so when
you had a thousand men in each class and
those are in the days when everybody
wore a coat and tie and that you to show
up in Commons for dinner you definitely
dressed that way it was very U much a a
university that was built on the the
English system it's like modeled after
Oxford and Cambridge and so it was a
very different atmosphere on
campus and so the way they selected the
women because there's a lot of
information about that that some people
don't see anymore is that the goal was
to bring in about 500 people the ratio
would be 8 to1 eight men to one woman so
they were aiming for about 125 women in
the junior class about 125 in the
sophomore class and 250 in the Freshman
Class to go through all the way and it's
my understanding that in order to get
the idea of co-education through the
corporation that Kingman Brewster
virtually vowed that there would always
be a thousand men coming in and that it
would not be unb you know unbalanced you
were not going to to disturb that and so
that was true for a number of years that
maybe it was 250 and then gradually it
kind of crept up and I think until
around
1977 um when you now have virtually
equal numbers of men and women but you
know that's a different at Yale it's a
very different Yale because it um
there's a book that's been recently out
called I think it's called keep the damn
women out and so I think that the
official number that of women who showed
up in 1969 in September of 1969 was
488 and I believe that there were 118
women in my class I think Connie uh
Royster who's class of 72 who's here
thinks I think that there were about
135 and Eve Who's in the class Eve rice
who's in the class of
73 um I think there were about 235 so
now that's what we we faced the key
issue here is yes there had been women
at Yale for about a hundred years before
that but there were two here three there
a few in the medical school a few in the
law school a few in the graduate
programs and maybe scattered around the
university there were
virtually I started to say no women
professors but there were a few um white
women who were professors
there were maybe two women teaching at
the school of nursing there were a few
people at the Yale child study center
who were were uh happen to be of color
but you really had very few minorities
teaching at the University in
administration at the University or even
going to the university you had Pitman
coming up through Yale College and
actually Bill Covington who was here
who's in class of 66 and I think you
said there were 10 or 11
um African-Americans in his class of
1966 so it was a very different um
atmosphere and you had um you just
didn't have a critical mass for certain
things to happen so it was hard to find
a ladyes room it was hard to find people
that you sometimes could relate to um
and it took having a critical mass of
women to have certain things
change I have to ask you how many uh
women of color were in that first in in
your class I counted five yeah and
because we were spread out and I was
married in off- campus I was not really
hanging out with with a lot of students
that much after after classes but I
believe there were five in my class I
think Connie said there were maybe six
in class of
73 um 11 to 14 something like that
because um somebody thought there were
25 total among the approximately 500
women who came so and we were all spread
out because
everybody you know we were spread out um
you know there had been discussions
about whether all the women should be at
the same college and then that was going
to disrupt you know the The Men Who were
already settled in being at TD or
Trumble or wherever they were there were
discussions about whether well women
should be in a separate entry way but I
think in the the end um women were you
know over on the old campus I think
together to a certain extent but those
of us who were assigned to different
places we we were very much spread up so
let's uh let's shift to Sylvia Boon uh
tell us a little bit about uh uh the
role you played in helping to bring her
to Yale and her arrival here and and the
chub that how did that all work well if
I came in' 69 and' 69 also let me just
say is a pivotal year' 69
is also the first year that there was an
African-American studies program not a
department at that time but it started
out as a program it was the first year
for um officially I think for the
Afro-American Cultural Center so those
institutions will be celebrating their
50th anniversary also in
2019 and a lot of what drove that
situation was a conference that um
Armstead Robinson Glend D
shabar um Don Olie Woody Britain um
Ralph Dawson my classmate and had helped
to structure on black studies in the
University which took place in 1968 in
the spring of
1968 right after the assassination of
Martin Luther King you also had Yale and
I know I'm backtracking but you also had
Yale taking in a lot more students from
um the private schools the more Elite
schools and you didn't have as many
students coming from public schools but
by 19 um 69 when I came
in um there was a a l more fervor of
what was going on on campus uh you had
women showing up you had more minorities
although you didn't have real a huge
number and it was also during the time
of the Black Panther trial here in New
Haven and so you and um it was the time
of uh just a lot of activism and a lot
of you know protesting of the Vietnam
War a lot of different issues happening
and I came in at a time where I was a
little bit older I was married I was
living off campus and I guess I was
still surprised at what I found at Yale
because even though I loved my my
classes I had very interesting
professors um it
seemed just strange to me that there
were no black female professors that I
could relate to and that they uh were
course that were still developing and so
I talked to some of my other transfer
students uh particularly Cecilia
McDaniel
about why couldn't we have a course
dealing with black women and as you know
one of the
choice aspects of being here at Yale is
that Yale Prides itself on wanting to
have all the intellectual stimulation
and having all of the nurturing that it
students can have and that we are
encouraged to seek out professors across
the university you know I sought out
Kenneth kenniston I sought out different
other people to that I didn't have
courses from but that I wanted to um
have some broader exposure from and in
that process we could create Residential
College seminars and so I helped to
write a proposal on having a residential
College seminar on the black woman that
would look at structuring you know a
course that dealt with people from
inzinga and Nefertiti through you know
Sojourner Truth and my um
Rosa Parks and just deal with
issues that we wanted to have discussed
and in terms of trying to how to find
somebody to teach that we couldn't find
anybody here but Cecilia had been at
Hunter had transferred in from Hunter
where Sylvia had been one of her
professors and so that's how her name
surfaced and when she came to New Haven
for her interview because I was married
and had a car I picked her up at the
train
station so in picking up her the train
station and having the interview and you
know having lunch and and saying now
this is a person who's solid she had a
background where she had traveled in
Africa she you know had a master's
degree in sociology she had um studied
abroad and compareed to literature and
you know just seemed to be so not only
intelligent and caring but just a wise
and grounded person she was the person
we asked to come and so she then arrived
in uh New Haven in September of
1970 to teach a two-part U seminar both
at Timothy Dwight and at Berkeley and
even though the course was not close to
anybody who was not a black woman
interestingly enough men didn't sign up
and other women didn't sign up and so it
was one of those rare and special
opportunities when you had I think about
15 women in each of the sections who
were black and dealing with these issues
with Sylvia and it was such a gift it
was so stimulating and it was such a
safe space and she was so nurturing that
it just took off immediately and from
that being so successful in the few
first few days I then went back back to
elting Morrison who was then the master
of Timothy Dwight because TD had the
chup fellowship and
so we then pitched to him could we do a
chub Fellowship on the black woman and
he was receptive to it and so with his
backing and the um College Deans office
and African-American
studies we had the first black chub
women as fellows the first women as
fellows I think and so uh we were able
to bring to the campus in December of
1970 in the middle of a
snowstorm um on the East course Coast we
were able to have the chub conf that
brought as you mentioned my
Angelou uh wendeln Brooks John Henry
Clark and shiry gramd
boys each a person a rockstar in his her
own own right and at that point in time
a lot of people did not know who my
Angelou was but she had just published I
know why the Cage Bird Sings and because
she had been Sylvia's
roommate among other
things not at that time but they had met
in Ghana back in the early 60s and so
she knew every one of those people
except for gwindel and Brooks who at
that point in time was the poet laurat
of Illinois and most people knew gwindel
wenderland Brooks but you know we we had
a fabulous fabulous coner so you just
alluded to Sylvia's time before she came
to Y and what else do we know about her
early
life Sylvia first of all say that pH
Sylvia was very shy she was very private
most people did not know anything about
her private life before Yale until she
died and when she did die in
1993 um I felt it was incumbent upon me
to let people know the full range of her
life and not just what she did at Yale
Sylvia uh was um the fifth and only girl
child of John Russell Boone and um Alice
Williams Boon and she um was like a
change of life baby she was born when
her mother was I guess in toward her 40s
um she had four older brothers most of
them old enough to be her father and her
mother died when she was still a nursing
infant and so she was then removed from
the home and she was um given to some
aunts to help raise her until she was
about 7 years old when her father
remarried and she was brought back into
the house the unfortunate part of that
was um the that first stepmother was not
particularly kind to her and so Sylvia
doesn't didn't really talk about those
times she referred to that as her uh sad
childhood of her unfortunate Beginnings
that um she really was miserable and
felt that she uh did not get much
attention from her father and that she
was mistreated by her stepmother and so
I think that's one of the things that
colored
her life moving forward because as she
studied and she as art history she dealt
with Mother child relationships um the
black Madonna mother is gold Queen
Mother we get a theme here and she also
was very motherly big sisterly to her
students male and female and she always
referred to us who had kind and loving
mothers as you you Mother's
Darlings and she
was very very concerned but that was her
beginning but she basically raised
herself and even though she was this
bright and and um um witty and
intelligent kid growing up um being born
in New York City but raised in Mount
Vernon when it was still predominantly
white
suburb she um you know just you know did
well in school but she was not
encouraged to try to apply for
scholarships she had a brother who was a
medical doctor she had a brother who
started Boon press which she was very
proud of and Boon press for anybody I
don't know who's old enough in this
audience to remember that there used to
be ads in Jet magazine and Ebony eony
magazine about color tone Originals
these were the first greeting cards that
were created that had images of people
of color on them and that was that was
Boon press and so she was very proud of
that connection but her brothers had
gone off often you know had their own
lives by the time she came along and so
um she basically put herself through
college in New York
City by working as a secretary as a hat
check girl as a waitress as an assistant
as whatever and went to school at night
so she went to Hunter she went to
Queen's college she went to City College
and she eventually graduated from
Brooklyn College she considered her life
truly started starting in
1960 that's when she I've read in her
own essays when she applied for the
ruthberg fund scholarship and other
things she felt that 1960 was pivotal in
her life that's when she graduated from
um Brooklyn College that's when she got
accepted into Colombia for a master's
program and that summer she went on
Crossroads Africa when it was just
starting on her first trip out of the
country to guinea and Crossroads Africa
was the predecessor of and the blueprint
for the Peace Corp so she went to
Crossroads um Africa um with the person
who is her leader was William Sloan
coffin who at that point in time was the
proactive um chaplain at Yale University
and people in here laugh because they
know the reputation of William Sloan
coffin and that was her group leader and
there's actually documentation of her in
a CBS white paper on Crossroads Africa
precursor of the Peace Corp so you see
her in the background although you
mainly but she was very shy you see
William slone coffin talking about what
it's like to work in Africa and what
they're doing because it was a volunteer
project but that's she'd always wanted
to travel and but that was her first
trip out of the country and after that
she made many many trips to the
continent and in um actually after
getting getting her Ms from Colombia she
also studied in Ghana the University of
of Ghana and she was part of that whole
core black expatriate community in Ghana
during the early 1960s that included WB
du boys um Tom feelings Julian Mayfield
uh Rosa gee um Alice wendam and it's in
Ghana where she met and was befriended
not only by kwami and kruma but also by
Malcolm X
I feel like there's a story there that
you weren't planning to
tell well actually she met Malcolm X and
in the slide projections but we went
through it very quickly there was a
photo that had a lot of people in it uh
a caller folder photo and there was a
man in the Middle with a um head wrap
and that was Malcolm X and it was with a
group of dignitaries U visiting Ghana
from um Nigeria and in the photograph on
one
end is Shirley Graham du boy and on the
other end is Sylvia with my Angelou
standing behind her so that was I
believe her first meeting with Malcolm
which was one of the times when he went
on the Haj uh but it was in
1964 the year before he was
assassinated and I also have um an audio
tape that um
um Malcolm's friend Earl Grant had
recorded at the otton ballroom because
Earl was the person if you've seen the
movie Malcolm X there was always
somebody who was tape recording him and
his best friend that's in real life um
Earl Grant and um before Sylvia died
Earl sent her this tape recording where
the mic was still live um after Malcolm
had finished talking and where Sylvia is
approaching the stage and you hear
Malcolm saying to his other friend oh do
you know the wonderful Sylvia
Boon um so there are there Sylvia had a
very deep um affection for Malcolm and
um I also found among her papers not
only um a letter she wrote to Alex Haley
about the last time she had seen Malcolm
which was with Alex Haley at the Playboy
club and I also found Alex Haley's
response to her about that meeting so
Sylvia knew many people but most people
did not have a clue as to what her life
had been like before yo yeah until she
died because she was very private never
boastful always focused on you always
focused on your needs always focused on
how to make life better for the other
individuals So eventually she does her
PhD here at Yale yes and when when does
that happen and how did that well when
she came to Yale to teach
the the seminar on the black woman
she she realized how much she'd always
had an interest in art history and but
she had not really ever taken any art
history courses
before she really hadn't but part of her
stimulation and part of why she really
wanted to take African art courses here
is because the man who's sitting right
there Robert Ferris Thompson who was and
is really the preeminent scholar of
African art and she applied because he
was here and wanted to take courses from
him and she was walking across Yale's
campus nervously going to meet another
Yale art history icon Vincent
Scully and can you imagine what it would
be like to want to teach you know not
want not want to you know get a PhD at
Yale having not had what she consider
considered to be um a spectacular
undergraduate education because she was
going from one school to the other you
know at night and she's going to be
interviewed by Vincent Scully who was
then the director of Graduate Studies on
her way up to history of art when it was
over at Street Hall Street Hall she runs
into
somebody specifically William Sloan
coffin tells him where she's going and
how nervous she is he goes with her to
Skully Skully's office and presents her
he said let me present to you the
wonderful Sylvia
boom that I know that she will be an
asset here because when she puts her
mind to anything she's always
spectacular that's how she got
introduced to Vincent
Scully and so not having a transcript
with any history of art courses on
it can you imagine walking in and um
getting into a PhD program at Yale and
once she was admitted all I've have her
transcripts and I have them in the
notebooks she had all honors in every
course she ever took and for her
dissertation she got all distinctions
including the highest praise from
Vincent Skully on her
dissertation and when she graduated with
her PhD in
1979 she also won the Francis Blanchard
prize for the the best dissertation in
the history of Art and she was
immediately offered a job as an
assistant professor here at Yale and so
she was very welcomed here and very
pleased to be at Yale with Robert Ferris
Thompson having already taught here 10
years earlier in the in the seminar that
you brought her that's that's a great
that's a great career story that is tell
us a little bit more about the
highlights of her she then has a career
as an art historian and hear it yell and
uh makes an impact on many students and
on the field well she I think she made
an impact on a lot of different U Fields
um and that's one of the things that I
thought was so brilliant about Sylvia is
that she was widely read she had very
eclectic taste she was interested in all
the Arts and she know you know but most
people who are at here read widely and
are very you know interested in a a
variety of things but she was interested
in sharing those things so let me just
start with her two books that are are
best known um one is West African
travels which she wrote when she was
still a student when she was a student a
graduate student here it was published
in 1974 and it was one of the first
books um specifically on travel to
Africa and what was unique about it is
that it not only dealt with all of West
Africa and traveled to West Africa it
really was a cultural introduction to
how do you feel about people and what do
how do you make the best use of your
travel experiences to understand people
not just go to places but to understand
how people think what they appreciate
the culture um and the introduction to
West African travels has a section on it
about how to appreciate Africans as
people of who they are not somebody
who's so different from you but what the
unique things are and the things that
are so common because she she started
out by saying saying everybody in the
world wants great things everybody wants
to be beautiful and to live in beautiful
surroundings everybody wants to feel his
intellect clicking whether it's through
a conversation or a poker game we all
yearn for Transcendence for Immortal
Life to be part of the
future if you look at people as though
they're the best that they can be just
as you're trying to be the best they you
can be it really color and and shapes
the way you are involved with people so
I mean West African travels was was
really a breakthrough about how people
dealt with Africa because you know there
were so many negative stereotypes out
there and she really was about grounding
people an understanding you know the
people of Africa are not you know
Primitives or not natives they are you
know people who happen to live in Ghana
they're either Gans or Nigerians you
know they are people who um do not um
dress in costume they dress in their
traditional dress you know but so it was
all it was all about educating people in
the most positive ways and that's you
know key about West African travels her
other book Radiance from the waters was
really about the sandai society that she
studied in um sier Leon and uh she
really looked at the image of beauty she
was really the um originator and Main
innovator in terms of uh analyzing
aspects of beauty um among um African
women and how they translate it to women
everywhere and so just all of those
aspects it it gave people a different
way of understanding what concepts of
beauty uh are you know whether it's from
your neck rings or to the way their
forehead is is shaped to um you know
freshness you know for instance on her
on her tombstone one of the things I
have is the word neku and neku is the
concept of freshness and neku freshness
it's you know you know how when you when
spring comes or even now where you see
the the little green Sprouts uh shooting
up the whether it's the the grass or
it's uh the buds on a tree and you just
see those fresh shiny green leaves as
they're about to come out that's neku
that's freshness the de on the ground
that's neku it's the concept of wanting
to make yourself Beauty Beautiful by
freshness and so I put neku on her on
her headstone as just one of those
elements of know who she is and how she
encouraged people to look at what is
beautiful in each of us what is
beautiful and appropriate about each
individual and so she had great impact
on on on on students just by you know
making sure that even in museums when
she was working with people on how to
have a um an exhibit how do you even
write about what people are looking at
so it's you articulate what's special
about it you articulate what's what's
beautiful about it you talk about the
people who were originating it who
creating it creating uh who were
creating the images or the object it's
not as Sylvia and Thompson would tell us
it's not that something was just found
because you know if there's some unnamed
person who created this there are
actually Artisans and artists and
sculptors and people in those countries
who were doing this creative work and
making things that were of value to them
important to them had symbolism in them
that we should know about it's not just
that you found this it's not just that
it's an accident there is a cultural
history that has been you know handed
down from for Generations and so that's
part of the impact of Sylvia and of
Thompson so before we open it to
questions uh uh uh from everybody who's
here one more question for you yes so
clearly you're committed to Sylvia's
Legacy and the passion comes through in
the way you talk about her and I assume
others also committed to her what what
is that all about why why why such a a
strong emotional attachment and desire
to keep her Legacy uh front and center
well I guess I feel like Sylvia was um
was like this ideal professor and I had
I had other great professors um but
um don't we all want to have people who
take an interest in our lives and you
know I'm who's going to tell our story
right well it that was Hamilton
reference who lives who dies who tells
your story yes that's that's part of
Hamilton's thing uh and that is that
that is true um but Sylvia made each
individual feel special whether you were
in her class whether you were a woman
whether you whatever she just she knew
how to really kind of bring out the best
in you and um that it wasn't just the
concepts and the ideal she was
was just caring and I I couldn't have a
conversation without with her without
learning something and when somebody is
so significant in terms of changing
one's life and uplifting you and me that
it's like I didn't want her her her
Legacy or her her work to just die with
her and she unfortunately had she was
widowed she never had children and um
with her brothers either having passed
or being very old and and in fact the
two brothers who were alive when she
died were dead within a year one of them
of the same um congestive heart failure
within months after her Memorial and so
her brother Herbert Boon um who was the
one closest in age to her and who where
our memorial for silia was on September
30th which is her birthday um Herby was
was dead before Thanksgiving of that
same year and so if I didn't do it and I
feel like I feel like I owe so much to
her in terms of my own nurturing and
what I had goals to do with my life that
you know for me it is it's an honor and
a privilege to just keep holding her
name up high I will also say this um and
I didn't mention this Sylvia was was so
knowledgeable about many things but
people here in New Haven um who know
that in front of New Haven City Hall
there is a statue of s sing B who was
one of the um people who revolted during
the Amistad Revolt she was he was a
mende and she was an expert on him and
Sylvia was one of the co-chairs of the
conference that took place here at Yale
um for the 150th anniversary of the
Amistad event uh the Amistad event took
place in 1839 I believe it is and so
that's when 53 slaves revolted on the
Amistad ship they were then eventually
captured and brought to court in New
Haven they were imprisoned in New Haven
and their case went up to the Supreme
Court argued by um Adams John Quincy
Adams by John Quincy Adams and they were
then freed and so um she was pivotal in
having that conference and she was
pivotal in having the creation of that
omad Amistad um statue in front of New
Haven City Hall so that she's she's had
a lot of of of impact in different
places and she's she's having impact
from Individual students whether they
took her course or not I mean whether
you know they were students at Timothy
Dwight where she was a residential
fellow for 12 years thanks to Thompson
whether it was somebody like um
um Richard Powell who is a Wilbur cross
fellow um has his PhD from Yale under
Thompson and Sylvia who's now a tenure
chair professor at Duke well whether
it's with Farah Jasmine Griffin who was
not even in the PHD program in history
of art but was in African-American
studies and English I believe and who's
now a tenure chair professor at Columbia
and you know undergraduates like
Elizabeth Alexander who eventually um
got her PhD and then was at Yale and
she's now at the Ford Foundation dealing
with cultural issues so she's had a wide
ranging impact but those are just a few
people that she's uh influenced and who
have honored her over the years that's a
wonderful Legacy actually to keep alive
why don't we uh turn to all of you and
see if you have questions about Sylvia
Boon uh about early days of co-education
about uh Vera's life any everything is
fair
game whoa within
reason and Mindy what time is it how
much do we have time we have uh yeah we
have about 15 minutes okay yes we
do yes we do have time we have a
microphone for you too it's a little
hard for us to see because of this
Spotlight but there's a mic coming can
you stand up when you we get the
mic out of curiosity how many other
undergraduate students black white male
female were married when you came to
Yale you know I have no clue I know that
there were more and because I was
married anybody who is married at that
point in time did not get any kind of
scholarship because they did not give
scholarships to the men who married and
so uh we were we were I know that there
were more I knew that there were men and
I know that there were at least one or
two other women but I have no clue sorry
I do I do know to get
married if not in those days a little
earlier uh you needed the permission of
the dean and so there are there are many
alumni who tell the same story which is
I went into Dean Buck's office in order
to get married and what they mean is
they had to get 15 bucks permission uh
uh to get married and if they weren't a
student in good standing he wouldn't
give them
permission so that's that's starting out
with the men and so those of us who came
in I the only reason I know that there
was at least one other woman who was
married in my class because
unfortunately she recently not not in my
class but my class 73 recently died
because it was in her
obituary um so I think there were very
few of us and one of of the things that
I heard by way of elar waserman is that
they interviewed or tried to interview
most of the women who were coming
especially the transfer students because
they wanted to make sure we were going
to stick it out and that we were willing
to deal with whatever we found in Yale I
think that they were expecting there'd
be some
problems and they were not wrong
the uh other questions
yes I think that's Dean M
yes
okay Dean Sarah could you talk a little
B about development
your sound it was really remarkable and
sustained and I'm just wondering if you
could talk about that relationship over
the course of your life both as a
student and going
forward well it's interesting I never
expected to
be great best friends with Sylvia Boone
uh when she came clearly I did not know
her before she showed up it was by
having that course and then working so
closely on doing the chub conference and
then the aftermath of it um that over
the years um I go off I I worked in New
Haven for a year so we we talk to each
other on and off during that year then I
go off to Harvard for two years um I
write her a letter of of reference when
she's applying for the Ruth birt fund um
scholarship and um um I was in New
Haven working with elar wasman and the
carnegi
Council on for children on a special
project One Summer and
Elga at the end of the summer knew that
I had was going back to school and I did
not have a vacation she offered me her
house up in well
Fleet she she did um and I say this
because those of us who know El Ela
passed away about a year ago and she was
just a sweetheart and but I had been
working with her with Kenneth kenniston
on this Carnegie Council on children
project and she offered me the house and
I was staying on Whitney Avenue and I
was talking to Sylvia that night I
started talking to Silvia every night
that summer I was in New Haven she was
in New Haven working on West African
travels so that she would be writing and
I would talk to her before I would go to
sleep and then she'd be writing most of
the night and when I got this offer I
said now Elga says she has this house
and it's got several bedrooms would you
like to join me up in Wellfleet up on
the
cape and she said seriously I said said
I said I won't bother you I know that
you're writing it was in the it was a
gorgeous location you could go one way
and you would be at the dunes and the
the water and you could go the other way
and you would be at a pond and she went
with me and I think that that was
pivotal that you know I just I I
couldn't think about not inviting her I
you know it was great company and then
we continued talking every night now
after that I talked to her every day and
she she became this Mentor that was not
just about my academic life um she
advised me about everything so we talked
about family we talked about men we
talked about careers and when I um was
working you know in in in Boston doing
consulting ing work and I was trying to
look at a change of careers she pushed
me about what was it that I truly wanted
to do with my life and I said I was
interested in travel I was interested in
the Arts I loved television and I was
interested in doing something that
worked with people and she helped me
structure two resumés one that dealt
with the Arts and television the other
that dealt with travel and then she
helped to coach me on that and I then go
off and do my International Development
work for a couple years come back do do
um management consulting and then she
helped push me in terms of getting the
job at NBC which then winds up dealing
with the Arts also and while I was at
NBC and I will be honest about this
there were times that were tough I think
that most corporate jobs have some ups
and downs and most jobs in life can be
tough and I would be talking to Sylvia
she was a night ey and she would be
working and writing uh into the night
and so I'd be going home or would' be
talking at 10: 11:00 at night and
sometimes I would have a voice message
from her the next morning when I would
come in giving me words of wisdom and
encouragement so when I then was
successful at
NBC and I then you know was eligible for
GE stock options or whatever of course I
want to keep Sylvia's name alive okay so
we endow a Sylvia Ard boon priz for
graduate students or endow a scholarship
for undergraduate students you know we
you do what you can do and so it it
never um it never phased me about if if
nobody else was going to step up to help
clear out her office and Mary Miller is
not here but Mary Miller who was the
chairman of history of art at that time
she worked with me and with Robert
Ferris Thompson to make sure that Sylvia
had a really
um well-rounded and appropriate funeral
here at Yale and that we had a memorial
for her here at Yale and that she has a
plot at Grove Street Cemetery which is a
Yale plot which is near her beloved Bart
gamani um and um that has um the imagery
that deals with with her important
imported Yale I mean you know we have on
the front of the the the The Headstone
uh a suai mask that was customized by
one of her friends that actually looks
like silia are you able there's a slide
of The Headstone isn't there um yeah if
I come up to the podium I can yeah come
come up um that has the but it has the
it has the image of of the the image of
the sand mask is um is actually from her
book Radiance from the waters but it's
not quite as it was so the head uh head
dress is a little bit different and
there's this smile on it that looks very
much like Sylvia um and um on the back
of the okay you well that's it yeah
let's go
back but you see the sandai mask so
anybody who knows Sylvia and I think
Connie can attest to it doesn't it look
like
Sylvia um so that the head is is a
little bit different you can see the
neck rings which were important um in
terms of the the sandai mask and you can
go on to the find the other one if
you're trying to look for the one where
I'm standing at the headstone um and on
the back okay there it is and so you
have the headstone the coloring is it's
kind of like um um the granite is got um
some burgundy in it and some pink and
some some kind of cream and some brown
but she loved burgundy and pinks so then
we have it chiseled in as the uh Sun
mask so Sylvia Arden Boon professor of
African art and it's the years that she
was at Yale she never talked about her
age so I did not talk about her age you
know Yale University and then it's neku
uh there now on the back which we don't
have here on the slides is um at the top
it's the quotation from West African
travels we all yearn for Transcendence
for Immortal Life to be part of the
future and then it's sylv Arden Boon
West African travels and then you have
three concentric circles underneath that
which were drawn handdrawn by Robert
Ferris Thompson and the symbolism about
it it's that she's lived such a good
life that she should be live into the
future so it's into Infinity it's
somebody who's worthy of living into the
future and so the symbolism on that
headstone I'm very proud of because it's
truly representative of who she was her
Import in this world and her giving
personality and um and when they did
something to celebrate I think the 200th
anniversary of grow Street the person
who was writing about the headstones in
the cemetery talked about it being one
of the most beautiful headstones in the
cemetery and so I'm very proud of it um
also the I think the place favor was the
uh portrait of Sylvia with me um and
although there is there's another
there's only one okay sorry that's Vera
with in between with huie Newton uh this
was for the um Eric Ericson huie Newton
dialogue which took place in January of
1971 and on the other side of me is uh
my classmate Kurt schmoke who used to be
the senior fellow of the Yale
Corporation and used to be the mayor of
Baltimore and on the other side of hue
is Dwight raford who's my my other
classmate whose daughter eventually got
her PhD from Yale and nothing to do with
me but she was chosen as the Boon Prize
winner the year she got her
PhD that's the picture the only picture
of me with Sylvia the only picture of me
with syvia so that's Sylvia at the chup
conference on the black woman there I am
with my that's my coat that's actually
my Overcoat um on one side and that's
Roy Bryce leaport who was the um um
chairman of African-American studies at
the
time that's the flyer noting the
memorial for
Sylvia that's the obituary in the New
York Times for
Sylvia she was in her 50s when she died
these are the people um marching to uh
dedicate The Headstone so you've got um
Robert Ferris
Thompson um with people marching with
the drummers in the cow
um you've got me at The
Headstone um you've got people um you
know marching into Grove
Street that's the only picture I was
able to find of actually not not true
there's the picture of Sylvia at the the
chub conference there's the picture of
Sylvia on the back of West African
travels and this is the photo that was
taken when she was a five bppa scholar
and she was uh touring the the United
States uh giving lectures she also
lectured at the Metropolitan Museum of
Art and at the Smith uh Smithsonian in
Washington and internationally but most
people remember seeing Sylvia with her
gala on so I wanted to have at least one
picture of her um with her hair
out this is the Sande mask in
ceremony this is the picture with and we
flip on it right away but that's Malcolm
in the Middle
and then you had
Sylvia and I I I flip on that really
fast because that is a photograph by
Alice wendam which is copyrighted
so and I and she said I had permission
but I'm so sensitive about about about
Alice being ripped off she was really a
key person in that um documentation of
of Black ex Patriots in Ghana back in
the early
1960s and and uh often times she's not
given credit so I give her credit but
you know but in that photograph you had
when people wonder you know yes Sylvia
knew Malcolm and right behind Sylvia was
Maya and on the other side was Shirley
gramd boys this is the cover from West
African travels of
course cover from Radiance from the
waters um this is one of the posters I
had for uh her memorial service and I
use the quotations that I really love
about everyone wants great things that I
kind of Remember by heart and U then
also the importance of so as the um
teacher of women so is a concept from
the sandai
society this is the last photograph of
Sylvia with her friend Michael who's in
the room with us now excuse me I give
you
as we hear from Michael um part of the
significance is this was taken at um my
angel's 65th birthday party that was
thrown by uh Oprah Winfrey and it was
taken in early April of 1993 within
three weeks of Sylvia's
death and if it hadn't been for Michael
getting her
there um I don't know that she I don't
think she would have gotten there um
she was shy she was reticent but at that
occasion where um Oprah Winfrey brought
together for the first for f that was
the first big party that she gave for
Maya after she met her and so there she
had a reunion with Alice wendam and Tom
feelings and uh Rosa gee and uh with all
of these different people and was
praised by those different people and
her uh Robert
um Lumis who was her editor at random
house when she did radiant when she did
West African travels and who had been
Maya's editor throughout all of her
books was there and so it was was just
very significant that she got there so
you know the idea that I have this
Photograph um is just you know a real
treasure to
me anything
else that's um
with David
Duo and then that's the registration but
those were some of the highlights of the
great you have time for one last
question yes if you could wait for the
mic just so we can get the sound on the
recording that is
Jeff oh and I let me let me say publicly
that there are several people in this
audience before before you start there
are several people including you that I
was just want to thank because you know
I am just so thrilled and overwhelmed
that um Peter and and Marta have given
me this opportunity to raise Sylvia's
name up to a new generation of not only
Yale people but to the world in general
I mean for me as you know it's one thing
to have you know a labor of love and to
want somebody to be nurtured but no
matter how much you might work for
things sometimes things don't come in
through fruition and as as uh a friend
of mine was reminding me that sometimes
we benefit when there people who really
did the the toiling in the field and the
sewing of the seeds don't get to see the
Harvest sometimes those of us whether we
deserve it or not get to really benefit
from it and you know part of my
responsibility is to kind of pass on the
things that Sylvia you know allowed me
to to have so the fact that you're doing
this is is is tremendous also in this
room is Robert Ferris Thompson a a
a that sh ofay of sh no she came to Yale
you know to wanting to study history of
art because of you and then when he was
Master of Timothy Dwight he invited her
to be a residential fellow and she lived
at TD for the last 12 years of her life
now um we have other people here now
Jeff brenzel allowed me to keep that
office at Timothy Dwight and so did and
so did head of
college is that the term right Mary Lou
who's who's uh who's who's allowed me to
to keep you know her her things there
and and work on these uh these aspects
you know I mentioned a couple of my my
uh colleagues who came in at the same
time Connie Royster is here from the
class of 72 Eve rice um Hart rice is
here from the Class of 73 three you know
we've got a
number Nancy Alexander is here who gave
the who came up with the idea I would
never have had the nerve to ask Thompson
to give me an office at TD she's the one
who actually had the discussion with
Thompson he said oh of course um so I
mean we there are people here who have
made my life
so um rich in terms of just trying to
continue to move on and I'm sure that
I'm overlooking people but I I I really
felt I needed to to at least acknowledge
those people publicly yes Mr Mr brenzel
instead of Master brenzel very you you
and I have known each other for a very
long time yes and had many uh things
together one of the things that um is
giving me great pleasure watching you
here today is uh that all these other
folks who don't know you so well uh get
to take advantage and understand your
own sense of connection and also your
unbelievable memory for people places
and things
so uh I'm going to it's it's astonishing
believe me um and I'm going to ask you
to go back down uh the memory well uh
one one last time to the chub Fellowship
uh uh program on the black woman and uh
my question is fairly simple uh uh but
I'm very intrigued at what you might
respond which was uh I know you will
remember uh that that occasion very well
yes what was the center of gravity what
did the uh extraordinary women that came
and were on that panel have to say to
that
audience uh what was uh what was
uppermost um in their minds and then
I'll ask you a tougher question which is
uh from where we are today um uh what's
the continuing relevance of what they
had to say in uh at that event you know
the the thing that was always
fascinating to me is first of all that
people got there because as I say it was
a snowstorm I mean we had planned this
and then there was all of a sudden a
snowstorm that was like about that high
in New Haven and people were having
difficulty getting in on the trains from
wherever they came from and people came
from as far away as Los Angeles and you
know down from Boston and up from New
York
um most people didn't know my Angelou
really and so but you everybody now
knows who myangelo is so that her wit
and the way she jumpstarted the
conference in terms of just involving
people with
um um stories about Africa and about her
insights I mean that was one thing so
was it it was it was the grounding of
ground well because it was the first
Conference of its kind that I we know of
that dealt specifically with the black
woman after black studies had started
you know and so you didn't have it
before black STS had started and so to
have it on a white campus was really
kind of unique um people
were um fascinated by Shirley Graham du
boys because she mainly dealt with third
world women she had been she was at that
point in time she was a widow so she'd
been traveling a lot in China um and in
uh India and throughout the Middle East
and she had a Yale background because
she actually was at the school of drama
back in the 1940s during World War II
and she had had not gotten a degree but
she is you know she was there and in
fact um Judy shift is here and she's
actually writing about her at her time
at the drama school um but the person
who really galvinized
things was the one who who looked so
reserved and that was gwindel and Brooks
because gwindel and Brooks was was kind
of a just a very quiet very academic
writer but she came in we by the time
she spoke we had moved into Strath Kona
to SSS to the main lecture hall because
there was an
overflow and she came on talking about
her friendship
with James
Baldwin and if anybody who's seen the
recent documentary you know I am not
your
negro you know who James Baldwin is
was she came on talking about James
Baldwin and that was during the panther
trial so she came on dedicating her
words to Angela Davis and the
revolutionaries in the
audience yes so she me and and when she
started to read she was active and and
then I mean everything was like leading
up to it so it's like it's like oh you
it's like you're tasting this from my
Ang oh no isn't that wonderful and then
you got you got John Henry going like
the meat and potatoes oh delightful then
then you got Shirley gry boy and then
it's like yes and then by the time
gwindel and Brooks came on it was like
Gang
Busters it was like Gang Busters and Es
especially since she was the one who
kind of looked the
most sedate maybe or the most subdued
and um and and oh you know talking about
the chub conference I do have a few and
tells I won't tell you so this was the
the the this was like the the small part
of version of the poster for the chub
conference but so the conference was
Saturday and
Sunday Monday morning the front page of
the section section of the second SE
second section of the New York Times LED
with Yale conference studies rooll of
black women so there's the picture of
and so this is the actual newspaper so
you have the photograph of Maya Angelou
who was wearing African attire and
Shirley Graham du boy an African attire
so that was
um dated of
course Monday December the
14th
1970 and for those of us who are black
or not not black but remember Jet
Magazine no Jet Magazine the Jet
Magazine from January of um I can't even
see the date on here cuz I don't like
glasses but it's from it's clearly
January of
1970 January 14th of
1971 CU that this is December so it took
j a while to get it but a four-page
spread today's black woman examines her
role with black men four pages so you
had pictures of Maya uh John Henry Clark
Shirley Graham do boys this is a great
picture of gwindel and Brooks looking
down and looking very private and then
you've got that's how you have the
picture of of of Sylvia and Roy Bryce
leaport with me because I was in there
and then Maya and then in the audience
you had people like arnab bontom who was
a visiting lecturer at that time you had
a variety of people people came from all
around you at that point at Yale's
history maybe there were a total
of 70 to 80 black women in Yale broader
Yale you know whether undergraduate or
graduate or whatever and there were like
you know 300 400 people in the audience
and they were coming from all over the
place great so before we thank ver I
want to uh first ask you a question and
then issue an invitation oh Bob I
just get you on tape so you wait hold
for the mic Tom for Thompson sorry
Thompson I just wanted to share with the
audience what Vincent Scully once wrote
about the writings of Sylvia he said
quote when I read the works of Sylvia
Boon I am always moved by the effulgent
beauty of her soul well that's very nice
that is beautiful how many people uh
learned a little bit of new yell
history
yeah thank you
thank you thank
you thank
you very
much so a quick announcement I come from
a culture that says if you invite
people